what is up firing the kid fam what a
weekend if you look like you have a
little bit of you'll see - OH - hangover
my man I'm not gonna lie to you flu the
- Oh Bloo you [ __ ] next couple days to
recover from Alan you shouldn't have a
flu inlet I mean there should be no
there should be no sadness I think it's
the and I tweet this out I think it's
the the best fight in the UFC and I
can't remember man
for me it was a it was a game-changer I
think it was not only the most important
fight in UFC history but it delivered
name the last fight of that magnitude
that delivered Floyd Mayweather Manny
Pacquiao terrible granted Floyd did a
great job but it was terrible fight see
how much hype was around this fight and
not you couldn't write this you know I'm
saying you literally you you couldn't
write how good this fight was and I
gotta be honest man when when Conor was
they made him walk out first obviously
lost last one and it's not even his
division and mates ranked higher so
that's why he walks out first but when
he was walking out I knew it was gonna
be a good night because how serious he
was if you remember the first fight me
encounter watching together at Franco's
house hit the first fight in with Nate
Diaz when he walked out and he's
high-fiving like he's in the club I
looked at Bryan went oh no he doesn't
realize what kind of animal he's dealing
with I went this won't I don't think
this can be good and bragging so I say
that went he's just not he's not focused
not being serious
he thinks is just another walk in the
park and you're fighting not only
fighting one of the dogs of the UFC but
he's also experienced way bigger better
boxer and probably the toughest guy to
ever walk through the asean as far as
straight toughness Nick Nick Diaz Nate
Diaz both of those guys are first team
all tough co-captains I'd love to hear
an argument say it's a different
so when Conor in that first fight didn't
take it as serious I knew he was in
trouble this one there was no games you
could tell he was nervous which I love
he was dead serious
mouthpiece in ready to go
but when he started doing well in that
first first round then he started
yelling like oh no what are you doing
man
I like whee he has to deliver those
antics and that that entertainment value
I get you gotta win this you don't you
lose this fight you lose this fight
that's two in a row it's over bro it's
over as far as there's no more mystic
Mac now you're Conor McGregor and we and
we can't we can't sell that it's a tough
sell you lose to neuro it's a tough sell
the mystic is gone so first round two
knockdowns you get you could have it a
10-8 sec round two knockdowns first
round one knockdown so so before I give
my critique of this fight remember and
there's so much nasty hate out there on
the Internet
it's okay to be a critical thinker and
critique the fight it doesn't mean
you're a troll it doesn't mean you hate
one guy more if you take your bias out
of the fight you just look at the fight
and I see the dear Saiyans posting
pictures when Connor turned his back and
ran in the 5th round
well Connor fans can post three
different times when Nate was sat on his
ass from punches to the face so you
can't take one aspect the fight say oh
he won because of this but by the fifth
round he was running no by the fifth
round he had to fight won and he's just
trying to survive so first round I'll
see Connor ten nine second round you
could argue a 10-8 ten nine well let's
just go ten nine for Connor so you have
first two rounds for Connor third round
you have a ten nine for Nate bye that
sounds like oh [ __ ] here we go again
maybe and he looked gassed he looked
tired that's why I was like dude you
spent six figures on the camp most
women's camp of all time you're tired
after eight minutes a fight like he was
tired exhausted granny's getting kicked
in the face punched in the face all that
so that's gonna hurt your cardio which
you can't duplicate in training camp so
that third rounds like damn here we go
and people thought that was gonna happen
I think Nate Diaz camp thought first two
rounds Connors getting tee off you can
get going he's gonna light him up and as
he gets going he's got sit there like a
tidal wave
I want anyone else in the world can
fight like Nate Diaz does he's like The
Terminator
he just keeps keeping finally I god duh
what I've tried everything I've got
little I've done everything just keep
coming forward you just you just finally
will and he wins the fight that's how
tough those guys are so that third
rounds like man we're in a little bit of
trouble fourth round the old mystic Matt
came dug deep he dug deep he could tell
he's in trouble we started to get his
flow back Nate all those light kickstart
keep started to catch up with him you
can tell and then I've seen the fifth
round so so you have first two rounds
Connor easy
there's no that's not even a question if
you don't think Connor won the first
round
you should never watch the sport again
and you should probably just go watch I
don't know WWE's where you can predict
the winners so first two rounds Connor
all day third round you have Nate
there's no argument there
ten nine round fourth round Connor again
that's pretty easy one for thornstowe
it's very clear to me there's no
controversy here there's literally no
controversy I thought the exact same
thing first - clear - clearly - Connor
fourth - Connor
third and fifth - Nate I've seen people
arguing lots of people including them
fighters like UFC fighters on Twitter
legit fighters yeah arguing that Nate
won the second round was probably the
clearest one today because you control
like the last 90 seconds because we
dropped them twice and he dropped them
flies no it's not the overall some of
the fight it's it's round by round so
it's very clear three two - I think
there's arguments so when I saw when I
saw flack on social media like oh no
don't let your favoritism and your love
for the Diaz brothers who I love - man
I'm so happy two million dollars thank
God man that guy deserves it his stars
only getting bigger you could argue that
Conor won that fight but Nate Diaz won
the war
Brian Kelly's jump about an hour and a
half late what's up man sometimes you
just get stuck yeah sometimes you just
kiss what's up man well I've been in the
car for two hours but I'm good and I'm
glad to be here nice Ben should be we
got Ben Henderson on the show today I'm
excited Big Ben I'm excited sorry to be
late
did you bring my [ __ ] cash is that
I'm I'm assuming you're late cuz you're
at the bank counting my task was good
you have it in a duffle bag you may go I
do I know you want a cab the juices run
I said I want cash and not a check so I
had to go and I kept counting it because
I don't trust my banker mmm so that's
why I'm late let make sense you know
what I mean and then I was counting it
again because I know if I'm a dollar
short you're gonna take hand in my face
the juice is running my man dude
speaking of that not to change subject
in for sure you my [ __ ] money but
because I caught 30 but the thing is is
I was lucky I can't wait to get in this
we got my brother from another mother
the the old Denver alumni been smooth
Henderson is in the building
thank you guys for having me what's up
brother a long time man I've watched you
on here for a while yes I've heard a lot
about it big fan and I got shout out my
boy
Christopher xub Ricky who loves you guys
really he loves you
steamed out a full write-up he emailed
me oh yeah I go over this you go over
this you guys talk about this I love it
Christopher fighter he's a real estate
agent and watching one of our one of our
best training partners okay high level
jiu-jitsu practitioner cases yeah a lot
of jiu-jitsu we guys that right yeah
down down in Arizona the YouTube
community is huge on there why is it so
big down there cuz when you think
jujitsu you don't think Arizona now I
grate it I think I think you I think
about Bader and there's there's a hotbed
for MMA yes now think jujitsu yeah
so you and Crouch move out there just
the the mindset of lucky old West for as
far as MMA is concerned why is it such a
hotbed yeah like the Old West mentality
down shootout guns so legal out there
everyone walks around so pissed off and
they have gravitated towards combat
sports mmHg to all the weather also
though I mean the weather also kind of
lets you work out outside or just it's
not as or not work out outside oh yeah
it's so hard we just did a show in
Phoenix and we got the plane and it was
ten o'clock at night and I was like is
this is this for real like I'm Xabi was
just the air from the buses back
who opened up the massive blow that's
pretty bad III really uh for me I like
the heat I really do enjoy it I quite
like it but when it gets to be a hundred
and five degrees still triple digits
when it's midnight when it's 1 a.m.
that's what I haven't well this is it's
enough for Benson Henderson you know
there's an issue and so on there for you
so my very first jiu-jitsu class was
with Ben and his coach crouch him is the
nicest guy when the best of all time
yeah at first you just took my first
Jewish class ever in this weird tell
Gatos boxing and it was upstairs many
years ago I don't know he ate nine years
ago and I remember the class we were
like warm rapid train with sky and the
guys like dude you gotta rely on a
stance is my phrase like you got a
relaxed man and then crouch came over
and was just I came in because they were
doing live rolling and I didn't have
enough experience yet to live role you
know I need to go and crouch goes hey
watch this kid he's because Ben was
rolling with a kid named Alvin Robertson
who's a monster Jews do black belt
fought in the UFC fought Kenny Florian
fought the who's who and at the time he
was the main thing in Denver so I knew
Alvin was and John couch goes hey watch
this kid Ben he's a wrestler but watch
him go with Alvin Robinson watch this
and it was like some [ __ ] I've never
seen before it was like those scraps you
see in the Looney Tunes or it's just
like the dust kick up and there's all I
was like oh my god what is going on it
was kicking up Alvin threw me a lot of
beans in those days first and you only
had what at the time one fight yeah yep
I remember super early might have you
been a wrestler for most of your life
yeah I started wrestling in high school
all-american right yeah yeah yeah Dayna
college and then so you guys went it was
crazy means you and Crouch took a risk
and moved from Denver and start your own
thing in Arizona which most the time
let's be honest doesn't work out for
guys hey sometimes it definitely cannot
it's hard to make it work out you know
we took a took a chance like you said
moved out to Arizona the original gym
owner said hey I have this ad art brand
new gym I had this dream of starting a
fight team and having a you know nice
gym and having regular student members
I don't have any fighters you know I got
this place about how many fighters do
you guys want to move out so he was
actually talking to Crouch II and Alban
kid Robinson in a few of the other
fighters I just tagging along okay you
guys all moving the Phoenix little do I
want to go too
yeah let me tag along so I tagged along
with them down to Phoenix and you know
the the original gym owner hooking him
up the per diem or not per diem but a
little bit of sponsorship in the mat
co-op the Mafia mob the gym it's all
that all that fun first couple you when
you were doing that did you in your
mind's eye see yourself holding the belt
as long as you did
I wouldn't say saw myself holding the
belt but I saw myself being successful
doing whatever case to be successful
working my butt off until I was
successful I saw myself doing that there
was a lot of there's a lot of
expectations on him we all knew he was
gonna be yeah he wasn't like this oh my
god Ben made it like yeah yeah pedigree
no just the way he trained he's so
athletic and just better than like it
wasn't he didn't come out like oh my god
Ben's doing like amongst the fires we
all knew Ben was gonna be pretty special
all right first one that we got for you
why do you fight with a toothpick in
your mouth seriously how the [ __ ] do you
do it not swallow this why it's just a
bad habit it's just about having no one
in right now I don't have one in right
now okay I have lunch yet
normally I'll have lunch I'll have
dinner or you know whatever mess around
I have a toothpick in and then I forget
about it I go train I just have it in
I'll have one you know going to go have
lunch and then I'll go to the venue the
fight venue afterwards I just happen to
have it in I don't take it out I forget
about it and then I'm walking up I'm
going to thicken
okay oh no no no no biggie yeah yeah and
I do have a practice all the time yes
you know my training partners like I
have practice for boxing will be boxing
I'll poke it out and I'll forget about
it I'll play that I'll poke it out I'll
plug it back in and you can tell the
guys who are like newer at the game they
looking back yeah you do yeah I was like
oh yeah I forgot I'm sorry don't worry
about it how do you not have moles in
your face a psychologic it's well no no
to come it's almost a comfort thing
that's just a habit just to have it yeah
yeah yeah the one
I'm actually rolling with Mike one of
the first times I rolled John crouch him
and I were rolling he caught me in a
very naked choke but it didn't finish
were naked he went to the neck crank and
said and while he was finishing the neck
crank he actually finished the neck
crank but I end up getting the toothpick
stuck in my freaking cheek a night after
that he said all was that it was the
neck crank tight I want I wouldn't go to
her naked I just it I went for the neck
crank and said it was that was that what
she felt for the neck pull up who think
was all bloody is like now my cheekbone
there yeah how long have you been doing
that for a while
my mom said I've been doing since I was
really young thing yeah she she's my mom
said I saw it from my dad he always had
a toothpick you know so I scares the
crap out of me now now I see mice my
seven year old son seven years now six
years now I see him running around
freaking out our backyard the two
biggest mouths fallen down and chips and
in swallowing the toothpicks I scare the
crap out of yeah how do you describe
your mindset to win fights my mindset to
win fights I would have to say it's all
about preparations all my hard work from
in preparation for me
I value nothing else on this planet more
value that utmost is hard work
putting in the hard work out I don't
care what it is you could be a cook or a
line cook or a chef or a reporter or
whoever I I value hard work so for me
putting in the hard work is why I look
to going into a fight if I did the hard
work I don't have no worries I always
use like the analogy of um because
everybody has experienced this most of
us have experienced this in high school
where you have a test and did you do the
hard work did you prepare for the test
going into a test if you're ready for if
you prepared for it you know not worried
yes that is the best I know this can't
wait yeah I can give this test to myself
yeah backwards forwards in and out no
problem but then also we've all had
those tests where we didn't study for it
all there I'm not ready for that one so
then you have your anxiety then you're
nervous then you're a little bit more
you got to be smart never to work to
write it's got to be smart hard work all
for sure because hard work and just be
grind let you see a lot of people that
are grinders yeah and they stay super
busy but they're working their energies
what quality work yeah
pew-pew always say oh yeah you can work
hard or work at work smart I'll work
smart hey I want to work smart and hard
how about now that's why you're well
champion see ya so my mics are going
into fights is how I prepared for how I
got ready for it knowing I needed every
extra sprint knowing that I did all the
workouts I didn't skip any I didn't do
this I ain't do that my mind ii went to
fights is uh if I did that hard work if
I'm if I'm fully prepared I'm good to go
well it's Wednesday morning I'm gearing
up to good or the Columbus funnybone
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm excited and
overall I'm feeling good Brennan is
wearing a wonderful striped a striped
sailor outfit what's going on my friend
what is going on I'm gonna give a [ __ ]
that you're in funny bone yeah well the
people do out there the people do you'd
be surprised what have you been up to
men what up - I have been managing my
real estate acting writing stand-up
crushing it driving my Tesla and
exercising and feeling good that's what
my things are going well no welfare they
couldn't be going back that's fantastic
yeah where the [ __ ] is my money your
money
oh the three grand hey remember when we
bet on the common identity the common no
no it was due Monday
what do you miss do Monday I didn't know
there was a due date on it give me a
second I have a lot of second ones
dating I know but I have a lot of can I
get a little breathing room please let
me show you let me get it to you in
pieces are you really gonna collect my
the money and mine click let me ask you
something have you uh you've seen zero
dark thirty
have I seen zero dark the movie yeah
yeah the movie yeah I watch it every
night every night every night before bed
why what do you mean what why are you
looking at me like that
I need my [ __ ] money I'll get you
your money dude well that's not do this
on the hey get off me hey Siri
we are I can't say what it does I can't
sing oh yeah I can't put it have to do
this out oh hey killing somebody call
the police what the [ __ ] are you doing
here where is my money please not the
water it's so cold my throne why are you
always late oh my god
I can explain hold on let me just give
me a second I got it don't put any more
water I saw I can't
I don't drink too much this morning why
are you always late to the snow you lie
all the time
nice okay everybody just give me like
god damn anybody just give me a sense
the money I got it isn't in my car let
me just goes I don't work I don't trust
no God no more water toast you know I
got ya good okay I'm again just let me
go to my nuts where right square hey
what are you doing my wallet why I
always have credit cards in there what's
going on what are you doing run that
[ __ ] 3,500 3,500 now the chance buddy
and so now we everybody auditions for it
it was this long crazy crate they
brought in fact when I got the job they
said you want to feel good I see yeah
and they showed me all the actors that
had audition that didn't get it and I
went wow this business so so let me ask
you so you do the audition it's the
longest hardest audition you see all the
guys in line and you walked out did you
think you got it when you walked out
well first of all the audition the
audition started in New York everybody
who was a comedian
everybody was an actor was auditioning
for this so you already in New York is
born you're in New York the audition was
there so you went and did the audition
did an agent to do so did word of mouth
I did some stand-up this weird character
and stand-up I was just starting
understand about how I was filming that
I just started doing stand-up at a place
called rebar that Dave Becky who owns
three arts and oh yeah he had put it on
and in fact David Blaine called up Dave
Becky and said you got it you got it you
got to see my boy Bryan Callen and Dave
Becky said all right and I sent him a
tape of me pretending out with a penguin
I was reborn a penguin fantastic but he
goes you're unique I want to put you on
put me on put me on in a guy named Ken
true saw me he was scene agent he was a
manager a manager and he had a tie and
then he knew the about man at TV
audition MADtv had fired someone and
they were looking for sort of a leading
man they didn't have a quote-unquote
leading man back then I was a cutie pie
they got any lady man who can be
physical and fun go and put up that
bat-signal for the kids go ahead put the
bat-signal you go to audition which on
what days Thursday afternoon well well
back then what you would do is you would
put yourself on you would video today
they would videotape you and send the
tape no digital that's it just via UPS
sir where to Los Angeles
yeah but what I did was I I went in and
the tape somehow got lost so my manager
said can you put yourself on tape right
away and here are the sides
the game is sides back then you had to
go pick up the sides at your alien on
email and yeah no such thing as email
some sound pigeons to you sometimes
pigeons they would send a pigeon I get
him I'm with Jimmy Burke who you know
well and it's a love I had to do a thing
with a woman to chill of her love scene
and Jimmy goes why don't you do with me
with him and did he have a wig out of
them
the he'd he had I don't remember he may
have had a wig on I have the tape
somewhere it's incredible and the what
got me the part they said was that the V
I kept finding out that he was like I'm
your sister I was like what
I'm also your mother Wow and I said the
line was what and I kept taking the one
I kept going which I got from you and I
do now by the last what though I went oh
because he goes and and I'm pregnant
with your baby and finally fell the [ __ ]
out and I get a call the next angle
you're going pack a bag you're going to
LA hey can we talk a little bit about
the McGregor Diaz [ __ ] man what do you
let's get your thoughts first well I was
training the Jimmy of the day we just
all talk about animals all man yeah well
I'll talk about UFC too so I was trying
to Jimmy the guy who went and he had
great front row seats and I was excited
about that I love that matchup I love
McGregor and I love Diaz and I said so
how did it feel in the room and he said
he actually felt like in the room that
Diaz won three out of those five rounds
and I was oh really I said obviously
it's a pro USA room because it was Vegas
did your friend get somewhere centipede
before a fighter I said I was like [ __ ]
it felt to me from an outsider's point
of view that McGregor fought the
smartest fight he didn't fight Diaz his
fight he stayed away he put a massive
kotnis Iran horrible cut yeah and from a
professional point of view did you guys
feel like Diaz was purposefully flopping
on a canvas to try and bring him down no
I I think karma Gregor's punches are
what sat him down but yeah
and and he did it before but it's very
strange to me like dear says this huge
following and I get it man I love both
those guys he took their legends man and
whatever's next for him you know we have
a and we do it here we have a bias for
conically such a big draw and he was the
winner we always talked about what's
next for a Conor but no one's talking
about what's next for Diaz cuz for Diaz
the biggest payday in the the best thing
for him is a trilogy fight yeah after we
make the most money no one talks about
it and Danny was our moving on from the
trilogy fun Nate Diaz alone the [ __ ]
yeah yeah moving on this is my payday
but if Connor had lost they would have
done the trilogy right yeah so that's a
real bummer I mean I thought yeah I
would like to see De Aza I like to wait
cause he's so long ago find out 55 next
he's gonna remember Diaz at 55 and he's
right number six or fifth in the world
at 70
he's like eight or nine I forget what
them ranked but I was left there again
there's this thing with the Diaz
brothers just resting Nate right now
this fight
there's people wanted to win so bad
they're they're blind to the fact that
just take your bias out of it he lost
the fight if I'm like its name the thing
that controversial yeah so when I hear
this and it's everywhere that there's
this weird controversial fight it's like
no I think in the room in Vegas
obviously and a lot of people you could
hear the crowd we're in ideas there was
a few Irish fans singing as well but
like I mean I just thought that kana for
a smarter fight he fought his own fight
he was he was he was in his head in it
in a sensible way much more and those
front leg kicks man like if I got one of
those front leg kicks are you like okay
and they also caught up to Connors too
and he's not a kicker so it affect them
they fight after the fight he collapsed
right this is my thing yeah he was on
crutches Frodo and Bilbo and a Scott
stuff so I got a phone call from agent
saying they are casting it's an open
casting for Lord the ring so it's not
gonna be you know you're not gonna be in
a room with five people you're gonna be
sit waiting in line like this it's like
American Idol 50 people do you want to
go and I was like [ __ ] yeah I'll go so I
went as plain is weird cuz I was playing
a skinhead in a play at the time and I
accidentally got into a fight on a train
there's no
and I didn't do anything these things
you were scanned it was kind of a thug
and they thought that I was in a fine
because I look like I was and and they
were like we're gonna steal your jacket
no that's cool and then they tried to my
Jackie and I got punched so I showed up
in in the audition with like not a black
eye but like a slightly yellow eye and I
was kind of like telling him that that
was the reason I think I slightly stood
out because of that and I knew the
casting directors and the casting
director John Hubbard who still is huge
in England said to me when I was leaving
because we he'd seen that play and he
kind of had been out drinking me but
with me a bit he said hey David Bowie's
coming in in the next hour or so so if
you want to like sitting there waiting
room and see David Bowie coming you can
do that and I was like yes potato pitar
this big one from today is that this is
not a complete done deal but it's
basically a formality that it's a done
deal
Rory MacDonald of signing with Bellator
after the UFC could not match terms for
his new contract it's been a crazy
contract let's go no numbers that way
yet the numbers come out or I'll get you
guys no no cuz yeah I know his agent but
it's interesting it's a it's a big
mutiny it's a big deal are you surprised
no no I know Rory and I so know Rory's
relationship with the UFC I in I don't
want to sound bad but we had Ben
Henderson on Monday and Ben and I I've
known been forever remember when Ben was
in the UFC and he's this UFC legend he's
on the Mount Rushmore of 155 if you have
one and he's sitting there and talking
and grantees older stuff like that I I
don't know it's not a knockdown bell
tower just like you really don't hear
about Ben anymore do you
you written you you just don't least not
it's just not the same yeah it's just
it's just not the same it's just not
absentia well the people get to get fall
into this trap of oh it's a there's
competition there's there's no
competition right it's literally like
it's it's CFL and NFL you know it's just
like it's like it's like MLS Americans
are compared Premier League that's
that's the better compare
it's MLS who gets the David Beckham's
when therefore desires who get these red
tires who they're out of their prime
they sign them they market the [ __ ] out
of them we tune into the big games but
other than that we're really not paying
attention yeah and again it's not
knocking about I love Ben to death he
knows his hot toys to himself
hey but when he sat down I thought I
don't know if I don't know man I don't
know if it was the right choice
financially I'm it sounds like it was
that which is what these guys are doing
for Rory you know he just lost a wander
Wonder Boy didn't look like he was gonna
beat him he had that amazing fight with
Robbie Lawler he's still I think he's
number two in the world
I'm Rory MacDonald I love Roy David
fires come on he abs loved or destroyed
an English guide remember when he got
this like I just did that I'm
financially I'm sure you paid a boatload
and really if you guys want fight or pay
to go up and fight the rise to pay up
the best thing is this stuff that before
we talk about Union or anything
competition is what's gonna help
everyone out so by him going there it's
step in the right direction they have so
many guys that have to sign and they
can't be older guys that it's gonna take
so long you need a rivalry to I mean
it's it's they're big shoes to fill I
mean when you think of mixed martial
arts you think of UFC when you are a
marsh mixed martial arts fighter the
pinnacle is the UFC that's your goal
well no no dreams about camp no one
dreams about being in Bellator name one
Bellator champion you know I follow why
can for sure but I'm just saying yeah
what was the Japanese one that was
around for a hot minute
pride pride pride pride go that was
bought off UFC bought it and shut it
down yeah
never monopoly for sure it's not even
argument if they have a monopoly it's
how they got the monopoly was it legal
that's the legal issues and that's what
they're going through it we they know
they have monopoly it's just how they
went about getting that monopoly was it
all legal and that's what people are
looking to but I for Roy I'm happy for
him again obviously I bet he's he's my
the hot I guarantee is the high
paper fighter I bet he's making more
than rampage which is a crazy contract
he's the face of Canada since GSP is out
I just don't know man I don't I don't
know